uh
sadness
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone welcome to the elder scrolls
online blackwood chapter preview event
hey eso fam we're so excited to be here
with you today as we go in depth on our
latest
year-long adventure back in january we
announced the blackwood chapter
which is part of the gates of oblivion
adventure
set in some of the same locations as the
elder scrolls iv oblivion but 800 years
in the past
it's the story of mehrunes dagon the
foreign daedric prince of destruction
and his pursuit to take over tamriel
the blackwood chapter which releases
this june is one of four new adventures
coming this year that's tied to the
gates of oblivion story
the first dlc in our year-long adventure
is flames of ambition
which kicked off the exciting news story
earlier this month
and we'll have two more content drops
later this year after blackwood's launch
in june
today though we'll be focusing on the
blackwood chapter premiering some
exclusive
gameplay that's still in development and
giving you an update on a new system we
know lots of you are excited about
companions we'll also pull back the
curtain and share juicy details on eso's
massive leap to the latest generation of
consoles whether you're a long time
player or a new adventurer
interested in joining the millions of
people who have played the elder scrolls
online
this is the place to be plus we'll let
you know how you can jump into some
gates of oblivion content today
for free whether you own the game or not
we'll be back in a little bit with more
info but now it's time to kick things
[Music]
off
a big hello to everyone tuning in from
around the world i'm so excited to be
here at sauce hq to share more details
about blackwood and the gates of
oblivion
i have both the honor and privilege of
representing the team here at zos
they are an incredible bunch of people
and it is their passion
talent and hard work that has made eso
what it is today
a huge thank you to everyone on the team
for all your hard work over the years
the elder scrolls online has surpassed
18 million players this year and we're
still growing
the response to our gates of oblivion
global reveal event back in january was
incredible we loved hearing how excited
you were about the return of a tess
classic
in mehron's dagon and starting your
year-long adventure
many of you already have by jumping into
our first dlc
flames of ambition
as many of you all know we recently
joined the xbox family
and we're so excited to work with such
an amazing partner
who joins us in our belief of supporting
eso
across all platforms and on that note
i've got some exciting news
today we're thrilled to unveil the elder
scrolls online
console enhanced which enables eso to
run natively on
xbox series x s and playstation 5
consoles
this is a massive leap forward for eso
and we're very excited to take advantage
of the incredible power of the new
console generation
to bring you both stunning upgrades to
both performance
and visuals making it eso's most
immersive and best performing console
version yet
when you make the jump to eso console
enhanced you'll enjoy
graphical enhancements to almost every
aspect of the game
including lighting shadows and
reflections that all combine to create
even more beautiful and
engaging environments in addition to
this we've also increased some texture
resolutions
filters and improved anti-aliasing to
help
bring out the details of the world of
tamriel as you explore it
the elder scrolls online is now by far
the biggest elder scrolls game and
probably rpg of
any kind on any console ever
and our team has been working extremely
hard to make sure that eso console
enhanced is both performant
and breathtaking a truly amazing
experience on
new generation machines trust us when we
say
this is a game changer eso console
enhanced
arrives june 8th and it will be free for
anyone who owns or purchases eso on
xbox one or ps4 stay tuned for more
details
[Music]
we are just about ready to venture into
blackwood but before we do let's talk
companions
as we announced in our blackwood reveal
event back in january
companions are your adventuring buddies
joining you in nearly everything and
anything you do in eso
that means you'll always have someone at
your side ready for adventure regardless
of whether you play solo or with friends
from battling dagon cultists to
investigating alien ruins
they'll be there for you you can
adventure with your companion
almost anywhere with the exception of
pvp or solo arenas
and if you need some time for yourself
you can always despawn or dismiss them
at will
there are two different companions
available in the chapter launch
and they are unlocked by completing
quests in the blackwood zone
all companions including any we might
add in the future
have their own unique identities along
with their own likes and dislikes
and as you get to know them you can
unlock new quests that provide
more insight into who they are and where
they came from
pay attention though because you can
build up or lose rapport with your
companions depending on your actions in
tamriel
once you've unlocked a companion they
start at level one and they can level up
by earning
experience and combat with you as you
level your companion up they unlock
new skills and active ability slots for
use in combat
it's your choice on which abilities they
use as well as their gear
and combat behaviors take special care
though when slotting their abilities
companions use a cool down and priority
system when choosing which abilities to
use
the order in which they are placed on
the skill bar is the order in which they
will try to use the skills
we know how much you love to customize
your own characters
companions will also be able to have
their appearances customized
using some of the cosmetics you've
unlocked for your own characters
including mounts costumes and outfits
there's still a lot more details to
cover with companions and i know you all
have tons of questions
we'll have a lot more info on this soon
so make sure to check out our website
for updates
and now it's time to explore argonian
and imperial occupied lands
known as blackwood
[Music]
hey everyone and thanks for joining me
on this adventure through blackwood
as rich mentioned back in january the
chapter zone of blackwood stretches from
the southern portions of cyrodiil
all the way east to the borders of
shadowfin it's here
that a mixture of both argonian and
imperial cultures will attempt to
coexist with one another
though this will be difficult at times
but
the two races will have to put their
differences aside as the forces of
mehrunes dagon and his cultists attempt
to sow the seeds of destruction
in blackwood when you first arrive in
blackwood
you'll be at the gates of leon it's
going to be instantly familiar to those
who've played test 4.
expect to find the great chapel of
xenothor near the city gates
as well as castle leon towering over the
city itself
of course being set 800 years prior to
test 4
means there's going to be some
differences as well our leon has a
proper dock outside the city walls
placing the city at the center of
bustling trade routes within the topple
bay
there's also going to be a number of new
marketplaces and vendors that have set
up shop in areas that may have been
inaccessible due to tests four's
timeline
due to all the city's excessive flooding
leon
is the largest city in blackwood and
it's also going to act as your main hub
it contains all the regular vendors
crafting stations guilds
banks and other services you'd expect
from a hub city
it's also where the main quest begins
you see
acting commander of the ivory brigade
rhea and lorne will have need of you
when you arrive
imperial councillors all who have
appeared to have connections to emperors
of the past
are in danger it's going to be up to you
and an old friend evely sharparo to
discover what exactly is going on in
blackwood
now there's a lot more to see and
explore in leon when blackwood launches
for now though let's travel to a place
folks haven't visited since 1994's arena
gideon now we're going to need to be on
high alert as we make our way to the
city
well gideon itself is a safe haven the
ruined ayleid outskirts are quite
dangerous
you'll need to be on the lookout for the
dangerous creatures roaming the swamps
like my new favorite monsters the bog
dogs and death hoppers
those aren't the only things you'll need
to watch out for either the restless
spirits that haunt the ruins of castle
geovese
a landmark that should be familiar to
those who have read the lore book 2920
are nearby as well for now though let's
continue into the city of gideon
though the city may look imperial its
leadership and rulers are anything but
led by the great keshu of the blackfin
legion gideon has been turned into a
home for not only the argonians who have
left the dark swamps of the black marsh
but for many travelers from the lands
around the area
in addition to the major cities of
blackwood there's tons of other
locations to explore as well
both familiar and new places like
undertow caverns
beyond ruins and border watch will all
be familiar but different
there's also places like arpenia
deepscoring hollow and blood run cave
each with their own unique stories to
tell you're also going to want to keep
an eye out for some familiar faces here
too
there might just be an archaeologist and
her manservant stumbling into some
trouble again
oh and perhaps a band of masked actors
from somerset as well
next up we're going to dance with some
daedra in the deadlines but before we do
a quick word from our sponsors
wow there is a lot to look forward to in
blackwood
there are a ton of great in-game events
new content and sales happening right
now too
beginning with the eso free play event
for the next two weeks
new players can test drive the elder
scrolls online on any available platform
absolutely free you can visit
elderscrollsonline.com
freeplay for all the details some
exciting news on top of that
all players new returning or current can
begin their gates of oblivion adventure
today right now anyone can jump into the
eso blackwood prologue quest
this new quest ties directly to the
events in blackwood
giving you a perfect starting point
along with something tasty to tide you
over until the chapter release
no spoilers but the prologue quests will
have you learn the terrible secret of
the longhouse emperors who are
threatening tamriel
you'll help fan favorite characters
lyrance the dremora
and evilly sharp arrow to overcome
daedric cultists and begin to solve the
mystery of myron's dagon's four
ambitions this is available to everyone
even players who are participating in
the free trial
and remember if you've participated in a
free trial before
your character and all progress carries
over so you can pick up
exactly where you left off and if you
want more the flames of ambition dlc
is available now in the eso crown store
it's also available to players through
our esl
membership or you can also pick up the
latest chapter eso graymore
part of the dark heart of skyrim
adventure on sale now before blackwood
arrives in june
that's tons of content to go through
speaking of which
[Music]
it's time to check out a cool new world
event that we're introducing in
blackwood that i'm very excited about
oblivion portals these portals are early
dagon experiments
attempts to bridge a path between nirn
and the deadlands themselves
and they're unlike anything we've ever
done before unlike previous world events
these portals aren't marked out on your
map instead
they'll appear randomly throughout the
zone and you're gonna need to seek them
out
to discover their whereabouts these
oblivion portals aren't the same ones as
in test four
a daedric army isn't gonna come marching
out of them and destroy kovach
again instead you're going to need to
bring the battle to the deadlines to
shut them down
when you enter an oblivion portal you'll
be whisked away to a random island in
the depths of the deadlines
because there are several starting
locations for these events you'll need
to traverse a number of different
pathways
each adventure to get to your ultimate
goal
this means depending on the islands you
traverse expect to encounter different
types of daedra
cultists and even champion mini bosses
standing in your way
these portals aren't just small areas
that you're entering either
you can expect a similar size and scope
to our public dungeons
just to give you an idea of how large
they actually are
now once you're inside the deadlands
your goal lies inside the tower at the
central island
be warned though the deeper you go the
more challenging this is going to get
once you do arrive at your goal expect
to face off with the daedra in charge of
these recent invasions in an epic battle
alongside your friends and allies
just know this is only the beginning of
mehrunes dagon's plans
but these portals are proof that he's
making progress
i look forward to adventuring alongside
all of you when these portal events
begin later this year with the launch of
blackwood
the blackwood chapter launches in june
and we're counting down the days
we can't wait to share what we've been
working on so hard this past year
but blackwood isn't the end there's
still a lot more to come in the gates of
oblivion adventure
we'll have more info on that shortly
after chapter launch
so keep your eyes peeled but before i go
i've got one last thing that i think you
will all be very interested in seeing
check out the world premiere of our very
first blackwood gameplay trailer
mortals they're always in
far greater danger than their feeble
minds could ever hope to understand
even now they continue to live their
pointless little lives
as they teeter oblivious on the edge of
complete destruction
mortals are nothing more than
insignificant grains of sand
but i must admit
i am intrigued by their latest
predicament
it has been a very very long time
since i've encountered a mystery worthy
of my time and talent
i will encourage them
they can thank me later
[Music]
and that's a wrap thanks to rich jason
and of course all of you for tuning in
blackwood is available for pre-purchase
right now this latest eso chapter will
launch on pc mac and stadia on june 1st
and june 8th for xbox and playstation
the free update for xbox series x s
and playstation 5 arrives with blackwood
also on june 8th
the eso free trial is happening now and
runs until april 13th the blackwood
chapter prologue quests are also live
right now and available to all eso
players
both those who already own the game and
anyone participating in the free play
event
and fans can pick up eso graymore on
sale right now
and play through all previous chapter
content while we wait for blackwood
be sure to visit elderscrollsonline.com
for all the details on what's going on
and how you can join in
on the fun thank you all so much for
tuning in
we hope you had fun today i know we did
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you